it would be a lot easier to deal with
the regime now in a targeted fashion and
I'm not saying we go to war with Iran
although if anybody thinks that that war
would you know I mean it would be messy
for a while but you know we've got the
ability right and and and look that are
the Saudis going to get upset about it
absolutely not right right are they
going to come out publicly and go yeah
yeah no but a number of countries in
that region H would have no problems
with Iran the regime again getting
punched in the nose and told you know in
in no uncertain fashion this has got to
stop you have got to stop this this is
this does nothing for the community of
Nations and you know but again I don't
think that's going to happen and nobody
wants that to happen but I don't see any
other resolution to
this joining me today is a former CIA
officer a security expert and host of
the president president's Daily Brief
podcast Mike Baker finally welcome to
the Ruben report thank you very much D
appreciate I'm glad to have you for a
couple reasons I see on Rogan I see on
Gutfeld all the usual places podcast is
great uh but you're kind of doing me a
favor by being here today too because
I've been doing a lot of racehorse
politics a lot of primary who's going to
win battle it out all of that stuff and
I'm actually really looking forward to
taking a little bit of a break from that
and talking mostly about war yeah oh
good lighten it up a little the several
impending Wars that are that's right the
world's on fire so let's cheer people up
uh can you tell people just briefly
before we dive into all that because I
normally don't even keep notes in front
of me but I was like there's a lot of
places on this planet that are a flame
right now and I want to make sure we
don't miss any of yeah that's exactly
right but before we get to any of that
can you just give people a little more
of your background for someone that that
may not know who you are and then we'll
and then we'll dive in sure um yeah I
you know I was with the agency the CIA
for about 20 years years going on 20
years and I was in what they call the
director of operations so the agency has
broken up into different segments right
you have operations you have the
director of intelligence they change the
names occasionally but basically it's
always the same four groups and the
Intel director that's where all the
smart people are and they write the
reports they take all the intelligence
they take everything that's coming in
right and you have the really smart
writers the analysts all those people
and then they have a u an admin
essentially section that does all the
logistics and they really keep the Place
running because it's it's not like just
admin for say a company that's making
widgets right you're you're running
Intel operations around the world so
it's a it's a bit of a different game
and then there's the Science and
Technology Group and they make all the
amazing gadgets right so think about um
well I could that desp on a rabbit hole
on that one Battery tech are you wearing
any of those things at as a matter of
fact I never travel without a couple of
gadgets but they uh you know everything
from Spy satellites to the program uh
Battery Technology if anybody's walking
around with a defibrillator right they
can thank the agency because they they
led the way in terms of miniaturization
right because you needed small batteries
for operational reasons right um but I
was in the director of operations and
spent all my time overseas which was
great um had a wonderful time got out
started a a private sector company that
does um uh basically intelligence and
security risk mitigation it's Portman
Square group and we're now I take it
that's probably going pretty well these
days all the weird things happening in
the world I think you know it sounds
mercenary but we do well when there's a
little bit of chaos um and we most of
our work is is is overseas you know we
do we do a fair amount in the States but
the majority is overseas and we've got
offices in a number of places uh great
people it's been a wonderful experience
cuz I had no business experience at all
none and so when it came time to get out
of the agency because I was raising my
daughter um I had to do something right
and I didn't really have a lot of skills
so I thought well I'll stay in what I
know and it worked out I started it with
a a wonderful friend of mine who came
from the British teams and uh we just
got really lucky and we met wonderful
people and we best thing we did was we
hired smart people right and then we
gave them the the objective and then we
set them on their way right and that was
that's there's a a few things I learned
from the agency and one of them was was
essentially that right bring on the best
people you can tell them what the
mission is and then have the confidence
that they're going to get on with it
right and now if things go south okay
then you got to step in and help out but
so we've been fortunate we've done that
and then I I got involved in some some
TV work and and some film work um the
podcast has been great we just started
that in September the president's Daily
Brief whole new experience I give you a
a tremendous amount of credit cuz it's
it's not easy right it's a lot of
gadgets mostly
hairspray well I'm going through an
awful lot of glitter and lip balm uh but
no it's it's it's an audio podcast right
now they they're turning it into a into
a video podcast um but it's it's a lot
of work so I you know I take my hat off
to you but uh it's been fun so let me
ask you a little bit more about uh the
agencies in general CU I talked to a
couple XC guys obviously FBI Etc and I
always find it interesting when you when
you talk to some of these guys who are
out in terms of how much they can talk
about and how they can take the stuff
that they learned and apply it to either
new businesses or just kind of what's
going on in the world without without
breaking protocol without revealing
Secrets Etc how do you how do you
balance all that stuff well you know
what uh you have to be smart enough to
know what you're not supposed to say
right and then you have to be
disciplined enough not to to open your
Yap and and and do that so sources and
methods you never talk about I've got a
very good relationship with the agency I
think in part because they they know I
respect them I had a great time right
I'm not one of those people who left and
and and talks bad about because I had I
just had a great time I was lucky in
that sense right and had worked for
amazing people and and worked with
people that were
tremendous um and so as long as you
understand what you are not supposed to
say right and you sign secrecy
agreements and those secrecy they don't
have a a shelf life right you know it's
not as if okay it's 10 years on now I
can now go on TV and you take that the
whole thing so you take that to your
grave and you need to respect that right
um so and the agency they they were very
good to me right when I left because you
know the their point was well don't
leave you know at first they was they
were sort of like don't leave cuz what
else are you going to
do I mean look at you uh so but I mean
they me it in a kind way you know and
then when I did go to leave they said to
the degree that we can you should leave
and be able to say that you were here
right and so that's a process in itself
and I didn't really realize the value of
that at the time because I didn't you
know again no business experience so
getting out um and being able to do that
that opened some doors that I hadn't
really anticipated and so that was a
very good thing how different do you
think the agency is now the specifically
from when you were involved because my
guess is 20 years ago there was a I
don't want to speak for you but there
was probably a certain level of trust in
the institution that now at least from
the outside seems Seems let's say shaky
at best yeah yeah there's a lot of
that's real yeah that that's a real
problem
um I'll I'll be honest with you when I
was in the agency for well you know
again going on two
decades I don't ever remember having a
political discussion never sat in a safe
house and you could spend a lot of time
sitting in a safe house waiting for
something to pop right because you know
for whatever reason you know the
target's not available or you're waiting
for headquarters to say yeah let's do
it we never had conversations sitting
around talking politics it just wasn't a
thing right and the agency itself is is
always supposed to be apolitical I mean
it's human right so people are going to
have their opinions and that's fine you
but you know you keep it in check right
sure um and so obviously the rub now is
that that's not the case right both for
the agency and the bureau the bureau is
taking a real kicking yeah and and I
think that's a real shame because
everybody I know including at the bureau
um and these are operators right these
are the agents at the bureau These Are
the officers at the at the uh
CIA they're they're terrific right and
they're not political and they and they
just do what they're supposed to do
right and the agency's job is very
simple right you protect the the
interests of the national uh of of of
the nation you know National Security
concerns and the administration tells
you what are your
priorities uh whichever Administration
is in charge and then you just march on
and do it right but obviously the rub is
now it's become a political
organization I would argue the same
thing that's been argued about the
bureau which is that takes place at a
much higher level right and you know the
director uh that's a politic position
essentially appointed by the president
and yeah you can get a director who's
who's too enamored with politics too
enamored with being at the White House
too enamored with that you know the
tightness of of that relationship and
what it means uh you can get others too
who are you know more senior but I can't
speak for now but I can speak for when I
was there yeah it wasn't a political
organization and you understood that
because we spent our time in some real
holes overseas right and some very
difficult environments where the
tradition was if the government was
overthrown and they seem to be getting
overthrown a lot then next thing you
know they' just sweep out the military
they'd sweep out the Intel organization
whatever the organization they had and
they'd install their buddies their
friends those that they knew were be
Rock Solid loyal and you see how awful
that was and what it would mean to the
that that particular country and so you
know you had a real understanding that
that was never to happen with the agency
so yeah I think we have to always be on
guard about that but the best way to to
guard against
it unfortunately is to have a very uh
proactive and curious and demanding um
oversight by the uh Intel committees up
on Capitol Hill and unfortunately I say
unfortunately because my theory is we
really don't send our best and brightest
to Capitol Hill right so there's a
couple prong problem here it's sort of
politics have been injected into the
agencies and then the oversight
committees obviously the Congressional
oversight committees as you said these
are not the best and the brightest so do
you think there's anything that can be
done to bring some of that trust back I
mean especially on the Republican side
now you're hearing candidates say you
know just blow away the agencies all
together and and a whole bunch of other
stuff what would what would look at like
a sort of sane Reformation as these
things have become political yeah yeah I
I hear that talk when people say we got
to fire them all you know whether
they're talking about the agency they're
talking about the FBI whatever or just
shut it down you think you know look
okay you're obviously too stupid right
to represent anybody you how did you
possibly get up on Capitol Hill no look
there's some very bright people I know a
couple of the people on the on the Intel
committees that are super smart one of
them from from Idaho U Senator R right
there're some very good people but we
also have some morons right so I don't
want to paint them all with the same
brush but um I think what would a what
would a logical step
be
I think one of the things that needs to
be done is that the after 9/11 they
created you know the dni position right
and they they basically collapsed
everything into one organization from
the Intel Community right all the
various Intel agencies and the CIA
director was kind of pushed to the side
right in favor of the dni who then you
know sort of had that job of sitting in
the White House more it's important to
have a better line of communication
between the director of the agency and
the Oval Office right
now you know you can well make the
argument that it just depends on the
President right because some presidents
are better at at that relationship they
pay more attention you know there was
always the rub on on Trump that he
didn't read uh the uh the briefings that
came in um others read every page right
it just depends on the person but I
guess my point is I think one of the
problems we've got is is we don't have a
better line of communication between the
agency directly and and the Oval Office
it's too important in organization
particularly in today's Times um to
relegate it to just a member of the
Intel Community um otherwise I think
that you've got to have better vetting
of the senior leadership right in terms
of when they're appointed right and that
again is job of the Intel committees
Congress and Senate
and then like I said once you get below
that senior level people are just doing
their job they honest the God don't give
a who's in charge just you know on
the professional level just tell us what
the hell the mission is do have any
sense of how much Dei has infected that
level that the level that you're saying
is pretty solid because my guess is that
would be the level that would get hit
the hardest been hit yes and and it's
there right they've they've done what
everybody else has done right they
played the game of of Dei and um I've
seen a couple of the recruiting ads that
they've run um look uh the agency was an
old boy Network right kind of the
original days after World War II it was
very much like a y operation right Ivy
Leagues and somebody to get a tap on the
shoulder and then be recruited and yes
you got a very homogeneous looking group
you know um so but from an oper ation
perspective you want a real mix right so
rather than being told that we're doing
this because it you know makes the world
a better place from a Dei perspective
I'd rather see the director instruct
everyone saying we operate all around
the globe and we better blend in right
in this case there are reasons that want
people of different color different Lang
exactly exactly it's a perfect reason
you don't have to play the Dei game
because you need to have that
operational you know diversity
and and so you know to me you know
having an equity officer or a Dei you
know director or whatever is is is just
it's nonsense right just do
your job which is get out there and hire
the best and brightest to operate around
the globe right and yeah I I don't know
it's it's you raised an interesting
point with that let's uh let's shift to
some of the fires in the world right now
there are many fires but as we sit here
as we sit here right now just I think
about two hours ago the Administration
has reinstated the houthis as a
terrorist organization yeah um they were
a terrorist organization under Trump
Biden one of the first things he came in
and did was undo that now we got a big
problem can you explain who the houth
give me like houie 101 what's going on
in Yemen can you clean that up for for
the average person that's just watching
another fire in the world and going yeah
why should I care why does this matter
you know yeah yeah yeah so the yeah the
hoties um we see the dancing videos
they've got got a great choreographer
over there get their guys out there with
the music and I tell you what you want
to I mean sa the capital of Yemen is a
is a fascinating place right um it's
very interesting it's an interesting
culture it's it's a it's a really you
know and that's the thing that you look
at and go okay well you guys are pretty
up but it's a it's a fascinating
Place great history great culture let's
let's get this under control but they
they basically have had a civil war in
Yemen uh raging for quite some time and
I I don't want to oversimplify this
but um a lot of the violence a lot of
the death a lot of the instability uh in
that region if you say well what the
hell's going on it's essentially a Sunni
Shia problem right so the Saudis you
know Sunni um Iran Shia right if if if
you know nothing else about it then just
you know you kind of say okay yeah you
got two teams and they're they're and
they're going at each other in terms of
of of their belief systems um Iran has
been supporting the houis they the they
find it uh in their best interest Iran
is people say this all the time people
say Iran is the state sponsor of largest
state sponsor of terrorism what does
that mean it means that they have built
up proxies right
um in in the Middle East in part to uh
satisfy their one of their primary
objectives which is to destroy Israel so
they have built essentially and
sponsored and funded and trained
resourced Hezbollah up in Lebanon um
Hamas um Palestinian Islamic Jihad um
and the houis in in Yemen I I'll stick
with those three for now but they're all
creations essentially of Israel or of uh
Iran if if Iran didn't provide them with
support and funding and guidance and
training and missiles and weapons um you
know we wouldn't be talking about this
today right because wouldn't wouldn't be
anywhere near where it is right um but
they do Iran's bidding in a sense I'm
oversimplifying a little bit they've got
their own interests as well but but
that's where they take their guidance
from for the most part so you've got uh
you've got the houti sitting in
Yemen they claim that they've started
this latest issue this this this
rocketing of commercial and you now US
Navy warships in the Red Sea in sympathy
and support of Hamas right and uh
against
Israel it's not as if the hooti sat
there to themselves you know they they
they're in a very tenuous ceasefire
right now and in their their uh their
conflict with the they don't control
they're not recognized as the government
of of Yemen um the government the
recognized government of Yemen is
supported by the Saudis right um the hot
is supported by the Iranians but there's
a very tenuous ceasefire there that
exists it's not as if the houis would
have said to themselves on their their
own without Iranian encouragement and
guidance you know what we should do we
should take some of these Iranian
provided missiles and anti-ship missiles
and start blasting them out and really
disrupting global trade that the Red Sea
channel that that accounts for you know
15% 177% of of global Shipping traffic
right um most major Shipping Lines Maris
kapag lloid um and most major companies
shell U BP others just shut down their
operations they're rerouting all their
traffic around uh uh the Cape of Good
Hope so that adds extra days adds about
nine days on on depending on routes
we're talking about that's fuel costs
that's crew costs that's shipping that's
it's just everything gets into that uh
everything starts to to become a problem
and so the hoties it's not like they did
this on their own
um what our problem is from a US
perspective and our allies perspective
is that the Biden Administration
currently um won't
address the primary driver of all this
which is Iran right so the Iranians made
the calculation the regime not the
people look the history of Iran's
fantastic right um and the people are
great but it's the regime and the irgc
the Revolutionary guard Corps they know
because they've been doing this for a
long time that they can continue to
destabilize the region and they're not
going to be paying for it directly right
any any response is going to be directed
at one of their proxies right so that
was that was a calculation they made the
Biden Administration is is playing that
out for sure you know they early on in
the conflict they didn't want to talk
about Iran right now they've at least
mentioned it obliquely this
designation that you raise is
interesting because president Trump did
designate them as a foreign terrorist
organization you've got different levels
of of designation right when you when
you say okay that group Hamas or that
group over there you we want to
designate them as terrorists you can you
can do that at various levels and it has
different impacts in terms of what
actions can then be taken against the
group so the Trump Administration listed
houis as a foreign terrorist
organization and then um I know Trump in
February of 21 or sorry Biden when he
came in so it was February of 2021
reversed that decision and he reversed
it because the UN and others were saying
oh this is terrible you know you can't
keep them on the terrorist L because
it's hurting you know Yemen it's hurting
the people of Yemen and you know they're
not getting humanitarian Aid and and
well you know most of that humanitarian
Aid was getting rifled through by the by
the hoodis anyway right it sounds
exactly like what's happened with Hamas
and with Hezbollah exact that's exactly
right yeah Hamas is the leadership is
Rich because of all the billions that
they control when money and Aid goes
into Gaza right they so anyway but with
the with the hoties the the bid
administration had no choice I think
from an optic from for politics um they
realized okay we now have to reverse our
own decision so now they've this week
you mean they had no choice now then do
you think then the the idea was well
Trump did it so we're just going to
reverse it like everything elence yeah
yeah I think like everything else with
the Border decisions you know that they
took on the border ridiculous right but
it was that idea that like Trump did it
it must have been bad right and so let's
let's just change it all because that'll
show how righteous we are right so they
did that with the houis um and now now
they've decided to go and reverse their
thinking because they had no choice
right I mean the news the media has
finally picked up on this and said okay
there's a lot going on here and we're
being targeted uh it's only a matter of
time you know before something bad
happens and then so I think they wanted
to get ahead head of it a little bit
right um and so what they've done is
they haven't gone with the foreign
terrorist organization designation they
went with a lesser designation which
is specially designated Global terrorist
right so whatever that is that's an
acronym I'm sure it's a government
acronym SG DT right so um
that is still important no don't get me
wrong I'm glad they did it but um it's
not the strongest that they could the
action that they could take against the
hoodies so what they've done here is
they're saying okay you know we're going
to designate you as terrorists you're
we're going to call you terrorists but
and that can allow us to to freeze
Assets in to a degree but they still
allows for humanitarian Aid to go in uh
again the problem is if it goes into H
if it goes into the port main Port there
in in uh in in Yemen that's controlled
by uh the htis so humanitarian Aid will
you know whether it gets to the actual
people who deserve it need it Etc just
like with the citizens of Gaza yeah um
yeah is is anybody's guess how much of
this of the craziness that we're seeing
right now whether it's in Gaza or
whether it's in Yemen and what's going
on with the with redc and everything is
connected back to the $6 billion dollar
that just you know a couple weeks before
October 7th they were saying oh well
it's it's fungible who knows what
they're going to do with it after they
had originally said no we can't go to
certain things and then sudden was like
oh we gave him the cash well we'll see
yeah yeah don't know yeah we can't we
can't keep track of our own money here
I'm sure we can watch an you know money
going out of flowing out of cutter for
uh for for the Iranians yeah I you know
what I think it was a it was a
definitely the wrong move it was a
stupid move uh it was misguided on their
part um did it contribute to what's
going on now not really because the
Iranians have been making Bank off of
oil anyway right they've been making
money so so I'm not saying that the 6
billion wasn't important because it was
right and um and in other additional
funds that were going there you know it
was that wasn't the only trch of money
that went to the Iranian regime uh from
the Biden
Administration but they were making
money anyway because we haven't we
haven't clamped down on on you know
their primary source of Revenue which is
energy right the same with Russia you
know we got made the same mistake with
Putin and you know the Iranians are are
selling and you know from to China and
Russia um so they have buyers right um
but it does point to just this misguided
foreign policy that the bid
Administration has had towards Iran and
I get it you know they they were doing
what they believed in you know
Administration comes in they they're
going to make their own decisions but it
seems it
seems opposite of what history has told
us right every time us has extended
their hand right to you know try to you
know make some deal or negotiate or make
peace with the ran they just the regime
smacks it away right and they keep on
doing what they've been doing and so uh
I don't know why they expected to get
some different reaction so so what do
you think a resolution of this looks
like so now we've you know there we've
deemed them a terrorist organization on
the slightly lower designation but
they're most likely not going to stop
right now so so what does the resolution
look like to get those ports functioning
again that that route open yeah
um if Iran told the hoodi stop they
would stop right that's that's the only
you know channel that that's going to
work with with the
hoties um if all we do is is fire a few
counter strikes at hooti stock BS of
missiles Etc and and most of those
missiles are mobile anyway right so we
have a hell of a time uh trying to do
Target identification you know create
Target packages that are going to
degrade you know their capabilities
sufficiently they this last counter
strikes they did over the past couple of
days were the British as well um and
there was some other support that came
in from other
allies uh you know according to you know
the military anyway they feel like they
maybe degraded about 25% of their
capabilities right you know that's
probably really an aggressive estimate
and I doubt it it's that much so yeah do
you how do you stop this how do you stop
the other instability right look Hamas
Personnel were in Iran training leading
up to 7 October right um their stockpile
of weapons the stockpile of weapons that
Hezbollah is sitting on everything it's
all emanating from Iran they all have
the same I mean the houis have the same
goal they they've got it on their slogan
is on their flag right death to America
death to Israel right um that's the
objective and so unless
we have an actual uh deterrence strategy
targeting Iran not their proxies because
that's what they expect and they've made
that calculation that they're good with
it um because it's worked for them then
nothing's going to change I suspect you
don't think that's coming though with
this Administration no no no and I'm not
saying it's a good thing I'm get nobody
wants you look the conflict in in Gaza
that's a war that Hamas started so the
only people that wanted that war right
were Hamas and and and Iran right nobody
else asked for it and so um nobody wants
conflict nobody wants War nobody wants
anybody you know killed I mean you know
civilian deaths are are are
tragic but we're going to have to do
something because if you know if uh if
we just continue down this same path as
far as the regime goes they are
shortening that breakout window for
their nuclear program right and they're
also at the same time shortening their
ability or or the time it's going to
take them to have a delivery system
that's capable right and uh because you
you got a nuke you got to put it on
something right
so you can tell I'm a I'm a nuclear
weapon specialist that was you do have
to put it on something you got put it on
something otherwise the next day in the
office ain't gonna be a't you're not
gonna send it by FedEx um so uh it it it
would be a lot easier to deal with the
regime now in a targeted fashion right
I'm not saying we go to war with Iran
although if anybody thinks that that war
would you know I mean it would be messy
for a while but you know we've got the
ability right and and and look that are
the Saudis going to get upset about it
absolutely not right right are they
going to come out publicly and go yeah
yeah no but a number of countries in
that region H would have no problems
with Iran the regime again getting
punched in the nose and told you know
and in no uncertain fashion this has got
to stop you have got to stop this this
is this does nothing for the community
of Nations and you know but again I
don't think that's going to happen and
nobody wants that to happen but I don't
see any other resolution to this let's
connect that to you mentioned Hamas a
couple times we I took my team to Israel
in May and my main takeaway of 10 days
there was how peaceful it was ironically
that that really was my especially
especially in Jerusalem but when we were
up north and we went to some of the the
stations that they have there right on
the border where you can see Hezbollah
literally you know 100 yards away
something like that and we went we we
started going down a tunnel and the guy
started yelling at me they took us into
the tunnel I started walking down the
guy's like you can't walk down there but
you can see it um what was interesting
to me is that there seemed to be way
more concern about what was happening up
north than there was related to Gaza now
there's a problem up North for sure yeah
but clearly Gaza was the the thing that
was about to explode I mean Israel is an
obscenely tiny country with basically
people that want to blow apart every
which way what what should they be doing
right now they've got North Gaza but
they're still hostages I mean what's a
what's a sane strategy what what gets
them out of this well
uh yeah first of all I will say this I
was about to say something about
Hezbollah but first I'll I'll give a a a
travel U promo for Lebanon Lebanon is a
fantastic country Beirut is an amazing
City and the Lebanese people are in
incredible great people I'm not talking
Hezbollah I'm talking about talking
about well the Lebanese people don't
love Hezbollah they're sort of held
hostage by them yeah and you could argue
the same for a lot of the citizenry in
Gaza right I mean they understand that
they've been screwed over by Hamas right
all that money you know you think about
how many billions of dollars and what
that could have done for the people of
Gaza you know Clean Water Systems
schools uh you know better road
infrastructure Communications all these
things and but you've got these
you know who who siphoned it all off um
and you know and extorted the people for
using the tunnels for moving Commerce
and everything else I mean it's it's an
astounding thing and yet it's all
Israel's fault somebody's got to pay the
bills for the Mandarin Oriental and ined
exactly so uh yeah but you're right
they've the military the IDF uh for for
Israel um basically is in a position now
where they feel as if they've got
Northern Gaza under control so they've
been withdrawing they've been pulling
their people out right and and and
equipment and they're doing the same
thing in slowly in the South right but
the South as you pointed out is more of
an issue right more Fighters um some
leadership still located down there
and the one the one truth here and the
hostages yeah and and although again
trying to get Intelligence on where
those hostages are located I mean there
been a lot of time this past right you
can and and so the movement of these
individuals right it's it's it's
heartbreaking
but
again there's one group responsible for
this right this this this is not
something that Israel asked for so
they've got to deal with it in in the
best sense and and you you pointed out a
very I don't think people understand how
small Israel is and again Iran circled
them with groups that they they helped
build that all believe in destroying
Israel right so they have circled them
with these terrorist organizations to to
accomplish this uh Hamas was very
smart um the the and I suspect the rgc
liaison was involved in this relatively
long-term project of disinformation to
you know essentially lull the Israeli
government into this sense of okay Hamas
doesn't want conflict and Hamas you know
is is good and so we're going to open up
more in terms of work opportunities and
and and allows more free flow of
citizens from between Gaza and Israel
for work and and that was a a very
intense covert action campaign right to
to do that and I think they also
realized once we did that once we took
away at least in the minds of some
within the Israeli government this idea
that Hamas was a daily everyday threat
and they wanted conflict and they were
looking once you did that then that
opened up the door for the government to
kind of look inward right and then you
started getting more infighting within
the the the the the government and I
think that that encouraged U Hamas and
whoever was guiding this strategy uh I
guarantee you these rocket scientists
didn't come up with it on their own and
so yeah that that part of it was was
fascinating and then when you think
about yeah I don't know I I I guess the
the point I was I'm trying to make there
is they combined that with the
operational side leading up to 7 October
again guided and trained um by the irgc
in Iran and their Personnel that were
based in Gaza and helping out um they
understood the importance of dumbing
this down right and so people talk about
what a intelligence failure it was and
it was definitely on the on the Israel's
part on mad and IDF and others
but in part it was driven by the fact
that Hamas understood what they had to
do leading up to this right so their
Communications patterns changed right
they dumbed down their there so there
was less Sig to pick up or potential
Communications intercept um they they
had a real understanding of where they
were going with this um but how do you
you know what's if
they if this conflict ends
tomorrow or ends a month from now or two
months from now and Hamas in some form
is
still intact and and running Gaza then
the only winners are Hamas and and Iran
right and the violence will continue and
the terrorism will continue and all so
that the the one key truth that
Netanyahu said at the beginning was we
have to destroy Hamas we have to make
sure they can never ever do this again
that's a that's a tough you know tough
call and it's and it's operationally not
feasible in the sense you can't wipe
them all out but you can try well what
would you say to people who say there's
no military Solution that's a big thing
you hear in Democrat or left leaning
circles there's no military solution to
this thing it's like there's always a
military solution it's the most Pleasant
thing in the world but it's War yeah it
is and and and I would say those people
that talk about there's no military
solution there that's a really
simplistic concept right and usually
they have no experience in a a hostile
environment but we did things in World
War II that that gave a military
solution yeah but you combine it with
other things right it doesn't just
because you you're focused here doesn't
mean you're also not doing other things
concurrently on different tracks you
know whether it's negotiations whether
it's coming up with what does this
governance look like when we finish with
this conflict they've got to get
themselves to a point where they feel
they have degraded hamash because you're
not going to remove them entirely or
you're not going to destroy them
entirely they've got to get to the point
where they feel they've degraded them
sufficiently that they are not a factor
going forward right and they also
understand because they knew going into
this right they
knew well before anyone did what the
narrative was going to be as soon as
they moved on their operations inside
Gaza that the narrative would change to
oh my God Palestinians are dying right
look how are dying by the way the media
never questions the statistics that come
from the Hamas controlled Ministry of
Health right right the Ministry of
Health from a terrorist organization
exactly ex oh sure we'll take that we'll
take that information uh and so they've
got they've got to get to that point
where they understand that you know from
their intelligence and what the targets
they've been able to take out and the
leadership they've been able to
terminate that they've accomplished that
they also but they did understand that
the narrative would turn quickly I don't
think they expected it to turn as
quickly as it did mhhm given how brutal
the 7 October attacks were but um but it
did and now you have a lot of useful
idiots out there protesting on their
behalf and on the hot's behalf what do
you think uh just to bring that back to
domestic side for a second and then
we'll move to another another part of
the world altoe uh when you see all
these protests all over the world but
specifically in America when you see
these protests and they're protesting
River to the Sea all of this stuff we've
got you know they're protesting at the
White House they're pulling on the fence
vandalizing all this stuff like are the
agencies paying attention to that like I
think most people are watching that
going doesn't even matter what you think
of what's going on in the Middle East
most people are watching that like
didn't we do this a couple years ago
didn't we burn down our cities a couple
years ago why is no one ever arrested at
these things are you just allowed if it
was a bunch of white people showing up
at the White House with hands on yeah
what would be happening so what what's
going on at the agency I know it's not
exactly what the agencies are supposed
to be doing protecting the White House
but it's intelligence involved right
yeah we have a good example of what
happens when a bunch of people show up
and rattle fences and
we we know what happens when they're
wearing you know Maga hats that's fine
and and and they they should have been
punished right I mean but at the same
time the inconsistency of the way they
came down on that and then you know we
disappeared on that rabbit hole but they
were very smart I give the Democrats
very you know a lot of credit for being
clever and sticking to a message because
early on in that they started using that
word Insurrection right and they knew
what they were doing right they they if
we can if we can beat this narrative
right that allows us to then do what
they're doing now in terms of trying to
you know strike Trump off the the
ballots so in all your years did you
ever see any other Insurrection where no
one had a set of plans and nobody
brought weapons strolled strolled around
took pictures yeah we move this barrier
out of the way yeah look I mean the
people that you know there had to be
consequences for the people who were
were violent sure of course but um you
know at the same time yeah the Democrats
knew what they were doing they they
played this one up and then people see
in general I don't I don't think it's
just Republicans I think it's both sides
human nature you know you want see
consistency you want to see the same and
so they look and they see this and they
whether it's the antifa riots or or what
took place in front of the White House
and they go how how is this working
because it seems not consistent in terms
of the way things get dealt with but
yeah the the the is that connected
purely to the politics of the agency
that agencies that we were talking about
earlier or is that is that something
else no I think that's a top- down thing
from the administration right and that's
that's a politics thing where they I
it's not because the the agency has
nothing to do with with that right
that's a that's a secret service issue
uh Capital Police Issue uh not not even
Capital police they yeah yeah they could
have a little bit of jurisdiction I
suppose maybe well I guess I I guess I
meant more in terms of information
snatching on the ground in those groups
figuring out who's connected to who and
oh yeah that's a bureau thing yeah that
would also be a bureau thing um and and
and you're right they you know they'd
want to know you know who's there they
they they
but most of those people out there
couldn't find Gaza on a map yeah right I
mean and some of them are you know being
busted they don't even know what they're
doing right they're getting a free
t-shirt and a hat and you know they get
to go out and you know and some are
there because it makes them feel
righteous you know and they like that
and and um they get to say yeah look and
they get to you know I know and then
some are you know trust fund protesters
you know they're wealthy you know I I
will say this
that people talk about oh you know um
we're all divided right we're all
everybody you know and and it's been
become very divisive and the
demographics are getting sliced and
diced the only group I can't stand are
privileged progressives you know right
because they just it's the
self-righteousness that drives me crazy
and and some of that plays into these
protest yeah there are you you get
others who are out there who have been
worried about this cause you know for
most of their lives so God bless them
right you got and we have the right to
peaceful protest I'm just saying that in
these in these crowds you got a lot of
idiots sure I would put the pure
jihadists with the uh progress the
righteous Progressive I would say
that they're kind of the same well bar
jih I mean like like like of Palestinian
descent right who have lived here now
and and you know have family over there
and okay yeah I get that right but you
look at some of the college campuses and
you think you you kids what the hell are
you doing you're doing this because you
think it's cool and it's trendy and
you're looking for something to to do
you know and and by God you can get out
there and and feel clever um que for
Palestine is very different than
Palestine for queers yes I think that's
how it works you want to go to the Far
East now or do you want to go to Eastern
Europe which way do you depends which
way around the globe you you choose we
should have you know what we could do we
could do this monthly and you could have
like a wheel of spin right that wheel of
we may well we may have to cuz none
of these problems are going anywhere all
right why don't why don't we go to the
Far East then because Taiwan just had
elections and they looked pretty legit I
mean people were actually holding
tickets and there were people checking
things and it all kind of seemed like oh
that's how it could work in functioning
democracies uh but there's a big
situation going on with Chi China Taiwan
Independence are they seeing American
weakness etc etc I'm just kind of you're
right you're right uh it it was a tidy
election it was a tidy election and they
they sorted it out and they were able to
call it you know didn't take them months
day um yeah but um yeah the the the
problem from China's perspective is that
the wrong party won right so they were
they were pushing there were basically
three parties and and they were
contesting this but there were only two
that were seriously contesting it and
one was the the Democratic um people's
party the DPP and the other was the
quman Tang party and the quman Tang
party uh is very much in favor of closer
relations with China China was very much
hopeful that they would win they didn't
the DPP won uh the vice president of the
dpb became or of of the government
became the president the new president
William Li and um they've been fairly
vocal about the importance of taiwan's
Independence and now that that word
means a little something different when
you talk to the Taiwanese people they
can be Pro we want Taiwan to be
independent and free they don't mean you
know rattle the cage and be completely
separate you know from China they still
believe in the importance of that
relationship right so we sometimes think
about it and go okay they're going to
have a revolution and declare their
independence and everything it's not
really what they're talking about but
even having some space between the idea
of reunification uh or basically Beijing
taking over Taiwan um
that is something that XI xiin ping
won't won't counter so he doesn't he
doesn't want to hear that so does it
matter in a way what happens in their
elections I mean I know at least
temporarily it's good for the Taiwanese
people of course to be able to express
themselves but ultimately if China wants
Taiwan it's gonna take Taiwan at least
at least with this admin American
administrat thing something like that
yeah yeah I think that they've um the
calculation is more about
um it's not so much about who's in the
white house as how long is xingping
going to staye of China right um I think
he
views U the reunification idea bringing
Taiwan back into the fold uh as his key
Legacy so I think if you could magically
figure out when he's going to finish up
being you know sort of this iron fisted
ruler of China then you could say okay
between now and that point in time in
the future that's when something's going
to happen and I don't think it's going
to be uh you know military they don't
want doesn't want to have to worry about
a military takeover and they've talked
about this sort of the the soft approach
and you can kind of see what they did
with Hong Kong right that was
accelerated and helped in part by the
pandemic right we were all over here
looking you know at this and uh and they
kind of stamped out the last vestiges of
democracy you know during that time and
it happened right now that's a little
bit different right you know in a sense
cuz you know Hong Kong was always sort
of temporarily leased sort of right
there was always a sense that it was
going back right and and so it's not
quite the same but they brutally Stamped
Out the Democracy movement there and so
I think you know their their view on
Taiwan um despite the fact that there's
almost no distance you know in the
straight there between the two uh is
they don't want to do it militarily and
and I think um you know they are intent
on doing it they've been very clear
particularly during the past year she he
has made some very clear statements that
it is inevitable is what he's saying and
so yeah the Taiwanese people look at
that and go you know and there's some
that that want that reunification you
know but uh you know the
majority want things to be essentially
the way they are right and it sort of
seems like if they think Trump's coming
back in a year they might want to
escalate that the speed of that right
that's what what G might want to do
there could be that calculation but they
play a longer game you know we take
everything in very small bite-sized
chunks and that doesn't typically happen
in in China you know they they play
whether it's this sort of issue or
whether it's an intelligence operation
or anything they play a real long game
you know so I I don't think we want to
read too much into just a change in
administration what what is generally
sayane China policy look like to you
like I think people hear what you said
about Iran and it's like you can sort of
like make sense of in your brain it's
like oh there are weapons in these
places there are trade routes being shot
at there's people being murdered that's
not how we look at China China is doing
a lot of other things related to
technology related to releasing Co let's
say like there's some other stuff but
it's a little more Tick Tock it's a
little more amorphous versus just like
military stations in countries right Tik
Tok is f people talk about Tik
Tok the Chinese regime would never allow
their children to have access to Tik Tok
right they have a different um ch right
yeah uh which is a cleaned up version
right so it's not on my phone it's on
that guy's phone over there and I told
him he didn't have to do it but he
wanted to yeah um but but what do you
what is like sensible policy related to
all that related to like an information
War that's happening to our young people
I will say that one of the things that
that um that the previous president that
Trump did um you know and you love him
hate him right you know he's he's has a
personality he's not my cupet I lived in
New York for a long time people in New
York who had a chance to watch it he's a
he's a he's a tri-state area developer
that's where I'm from yeah exactly so
you know you get punched in the nose you
punch the other guy in the nose I mean
it's people there knew what what was
happening and what the guy was going to
be like nobody thought he was going to
suddenly become a sophisticated you know
thoughtful individual who was going to
be presidential that you know but one of
the things that he did that was very
smart and I think very useful was to
elevate the the conversation around
China right and to put a spotlight on
just how much damage the Chinese regime
and their Intel apparatus has done over
the decades right in terms of theft of
intellectual property the cost of that
to us and to our allies to the West um
and just the outright theft of research
and development right um fenel I mean
fent fentel yeah I mean it's yes uh so
that's that's a whole separate you know
counternarcotics issue that you know but
um the it's their it's their
intelligence operations it's their
economic Espionage um those things have
done uh damage that we can't even
calculate the cost of over over decades
in terms of lost opportunity lost jobs
um lost um you know uh revenue streams
that could have you know supported and
built up other countries other
businesses they're incredibly aggressive
um and then you know what what they've
been doing while we again kind of get
focused in one area whether it's Iraq
Afghanistan um domestic concerns
whatever it might be we have a hard time
it seems uh
multitasking and again with their sort
of their longer view they have a
strategy and so they they've spent a
couple of decades now traveling around
the world people for the most part know
about this belt and Road initiative that
that China has but they been going
around locking up as an example uh
locking up uh Mining rights right in
South America or in Africa um for key
minerals right critical and rare earth
minerals um and it's the critical
minerals that are really more important
I always thought we call it rare earth
and people think well those are the
important ones you're thinking well it's
more really the critical minerals
they've been locking up uh those
opportunities right they have a monopoly
on processing of of key minerals that
we're never going to get to 100% you
know
green um because we don't have the
ability to process much less mine but to
process and refine those those minerals
for things that we need such as I don't
know batteries right and so you hear
this talk about you know uh Battery
Technology and how we're all going to go
in that direction and that's great we
should be doing lots of different things
right for energy but the Chinese knew
that years ago and they had a plan and
they've been doing this
um and they also do other things they do
things that are more Insidious than just
going around and cutting deals right
usually it's in a sort of a Usery
situation where the the country finds
out that they're doing a deal with that
country then finds out a few years later
that they're completely in debt can't
afford the loans end up having to give
up more right um but the some of the
Insidious things that they do the
Chinese regime and the Intel apparatus
understood the importance of of uh
regulatory uh decisions right
regulations here in the US and the
impact that would have on things mining
right uh or Agriculture and so as an
example they're not trying
necessarily well they are but it's not
they don't consider it the most
important part they're influencing local
communities they're influencing local
politics State politics at that level
right to make decisions about about
regulations um phosphate phosphat is a
good example it's a very good example
right you like food you like large scale
agriculture to feed the world better
have some phosphate right it's
fertilizer so um leading producers of of
phosphate China uh Morocco Russia little
you know just they're they're up there
but
so the they understood if we go in and
we impact local community decisions
about you know access to phosphate
mining right and that and and we promote
or we encourage you know through a
variety of ways right supporting local
activist groups supporting uh operations
that you know that they're more on
National basis that try to do
environmental concerns right they're
trying to do good things right the these
activists and the environment they're
it's not like it's it's nefarious and
they say if we could just cut a deal
with the Chinese regime but the Chinese
regime understands this and so through a
variety of cutouts they're able to
support these groups and next thing you
know whether it's down in Florida you
know with phosphate or it's anywhere
else you know towns or city councils are
saying no we don't want that you know we
don't want we're going to have to do
something about that shut it down
that's an enormous benefit to a country
that is the you know key producer of
that mineral so that's something that
they do and that that and I I'm I've
been fascinated by that because it shows
again it shows this Long View and from
an operational perspective sometimes the
problems with the CIA is that we we tend
to have a shorter view right we're
Americans and so that's just a tendency
and so our operations tend to have a
shorter time frame concern right um we
don't sometimes think about putting in
the the hard work of 10 to 20 years or
25 years to develop an asset right or to
develop a program that's going to
eventually produce results and that's
and that and that also gets us exactly
back to where we started which is why
you don't want politics in the agency
because then that's going to flip that
long-term thing because administrations
are going to come and go let's just
spend the remaining time going a little
we'll just we went really far east we'll
kind of come back a little bit no no no
let's uh let's just do a little bit
about Russia and Ukraine my my basic
position on on this thing from the
beginning was if we were going to do
anything there you got to be really
careful cuz the guy's got nukes so you
can't just keep saying okay arm and arm
him arm him because at the end of the
day if we got that close to the
precipice he's got nukes so you better
watch out and not just nukes he's got
those things that you put them on and
the things that you mentioned before
that they put them on they shoot them
all over the place right so that was
sort of my position the whole time and I
I just don't like blank checks to
everybody and we're paying pensions for
their people all of that stuff it seems
to me it's sort of been pushed to the
side at the moment because of October
7th so we sort of stopped talking about
it yeah uh but zalinski is at the WF
right now in Davos the war's not gone
anywhere I mean what in the what's going
on there right now yeah it is it is
fascinating isn't it because it was uh
it was all Ukraine all day long right um
and then s October happened and
naturally that Drew a lot of focus but
it is interesting that we again we have
a hard time multitasking in and
including in the media where it's just
like you we went for a couple of weeks
before anybody thought is is there
something going on still in Ukraine
right um and and there is they're in the
the winter season which is brutal over
there and they understood going into the
winter season that there was going to be
very little ground movement right and so
it's it's harder to to redeploy troops
harded to move supplies so they kind of
hunker down it's very World War oneish
right you got the trench warfare
literally the sovi the Soviets the
Russians have built enormous trench uh
lines and it's it's incredible I was at
the it's hard to believe people still
fight like that it's hard you know I I
was I was going to say I I took the boys
I'm I'm dual citizen I was born in
England and uh so and the boys have
their citizenship so I took all three of
them um with with my wife who's the
greatest person I'll ever know and we
went to London and I took him to the uh
Imperial War Museum and anybody you know
goes to London they they have to go to
the Imperial War Museum it's an amazing
place they have a World War One exhibit
so we're walking around this was last uh
last summer we're walking through the
exhibit and I've got the boys scooter
and Sluggo and Mugsy and we're we're
walking through this World War I exhibit
and we're and we're reading the the all
the about the trench warfare and we're
reading about how it impacted uh
Agriculture and so it it created food
shortages and it cre all the things that
were happening in World War I and and it
was happening in in Ukraine at that
moment you think how do we possibly
regress how did we go back to this but
we did and so getting back to the
present time uh the war has shifted its
focus now it's a longer range War during
the winter months right um and so what
does that mean that means ukrainians are
are using their available Munitions
missiles to um to go after Russian
supply lines further in to uh or further
behind the lines and sometimes into
Russia and they're going after the
command and control centers and there so
there's this long range battle they're
they're trying to do more targeted uh
strategic strikes on on on uh on
leadership ship right and and that's a
that's that's a hard lift they're trying
to to uh basically cut off Crimea right
and Putin's doing the same thing he did
the same thing last winter he's lobbing
missiles at infrastructure he's trying
to freeze out the ukrainians during the
winter months right so he's hitting
energy sources as much as he can um and
it's brutal right and Russia's got a
Manpower problem uh but they have a
three to one advantage just in sheer
numbers right so they're they're busy
conscripting and and and emptying out
their prisons um the ukrainians have
their own problems they've got some
internal a little bit of internal
infighting right um in part because of
just this dissatisfaction right of over
the lack of of success during that
counter offensive right they really were
banking on that and that had an impact
when it didn't go out that way it also
had an impact here in the states where
you started to get this this this idea
that wait a minute what are we doing
right took us 20 years to get fatigued
from Afghanistan took us two years in
Ukraine fighting Putin right through you
know you could argue right you could
argue that it's you know Ukraine's a
proxy right and we're and you you'll
hear this from you know military
personnel they're saying well look this
is a a a this a small cost to pay to
degrade to the degree that we've done or
the ukrainians have done the Russian
military right and it's also shown a lot
of weaknesses in the Russian military
structure and and so um we can't if we
stop providing
support to um to uh to Ukraine I'm not
saying we continue with a certain level
I think we should be more strategic
about the Weaponry we're providing them
um Putin will go on the offensive and
it's just a matter of time before he
would then have success right and he
could well end up in ke and that's what
he's counting on he's count counting on
the same thing that the Chinese count on
with the US which is we have a short
attention span we're going to get tired
of it we're going to move on to
something else and that's what he's
banking on he has shown no interest
really in serious negotiation right um
and the only interest he would show is
if the ukrainians said okay you can have
everything you've got right now right
he's not going to give up Putin's not
going to give up happily or willingly
Crimea so is that the weird part when
you hear from our Congress people and
Senators when they're like well we just
have to keep arming them and it's like
well that just doesn't get us to a
resolution Because unless you're going
to take him out and make sure that the
next guy doesn't launch some nukes
they're just not going to end this thing
yeah and that's the problem is that
nobody's talked about the uh the road
mapap for you know where's the exit ramp
right and so um but but the reality is
zilinsky you know came out said we're
going to take all our territory we're
not you know we're not going to the
table until we get everything back and
again Putin's not giving up Crimea we
nobody gave us about Crimea right
being taken over by the Russians years
ago it was not like people in the states
weren't waving Ukrainian flags and you
know it was whole different thing it was
yeah so so it happened and we didn't
care but now we're like what now we're
supposed to like stand and say you know
because it makes us feel good um there's
got to be a there's got to be a solution
here where they're both going to not
particularly be happy which is the
typical way that you end these things is
both sides are a little bit displeased
but you know Putin's going to you know
again he's not going to give up
willingly Crimea um you know can they
get back more of their territory on the
Eastern side you know that would be nice
to think so but you know there's got to
be a resolution to this because we can't
keep providing at the same level and our
NATO allies they won't right they've got
their own it's we're Dickering in in
Congress about the aid package they're
doing the same thing in in in the EU
so um and and that's got zalinsky wor
but it's playing into Putin's
expectations right that we were going to
get tired of it and they're doing their
own disinformation campaign right to try
to influence public opinion here right
about that and yeah and then which is to
be expected anyway so it's it's a I
guess the answer is uh I have no clue
it's above my pay
grade that seems like a fitting way to
end Mike I have to say this was an
absolute pleasure talking about Wars all
over the world instead of our political
Wars so I thank you for coming thank you
D I appreciate appreciate it if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop screaming check out our
politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell